si le trafic ferroviaire devrait être
quasi normal ce lundi sur les réseaux
sncf et ratp
la mobilisation se poursuit contre la
réforme des retraites après les avocats
les enseignants les pompiers ou encore
les cheminots ce sont désormais les
soldats qui viennent s'ajouter à la
longue liste des professions en colère
farouchement opposé à ce projet de loi
le conseil supérieur de la fonction
militaire estime que certaines
dispositions fragilise notre modèle
d'armée l'instance craint entre autres
une baisse des pensions pour certains
militaires et une augmentation de la
durée de cotisation le gouvernement leur
avait pourtant promis une retraite après
une carrière de 17 à 27 années selon les
rangs plusieurs personnalités politiques
ont abondé dans le sens de l'armée c'est
le cas du premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste
le conseil supérieur de la fonction
militaire
saisi par le ministre des armées pour se
prononcer sur la réforme des retraites
vient de rendre un avis négatif
la question c'est qui soutient vraiment
ce projet alors que la grogne gagne les
militaires et malgré le mouvement des
gilet jaune
emmanuel macron a décidé de maintenir
shoes friends un événement annuel qui a
lieu ce lundi à versailles
lors de cette réunion annuelle des chefs
d'entreprise étrangers se voit présenter
les différents secteurs d'investissement
en france
le président tentera de convaincre ses
200 patrons de miser sur le pays
malgré un contexte compliqué selon
l'elysée près de 4 milliards d'euros
devraient être investis en france par
des grands groupes
la cgt ile-de-france a appelé à
manifester dès 10 heures à partir de la
gare de versailles chantiers un début de
semaine déjà mouvementée qui se
terminera avec une nouvelle journée
massive de grèves et de manifestations
le vendredi 24 janvier jour de la
présentation officielle du projet de
réforme des retraites en conseil des
ministres
[Musique]